movie clips Fandango here to see Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles we just saw ninja
turtle and I really want to tell Bunga
dude hi I'm David and I'm Zach and we
saw Ninja Turtles the new new Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movie with Megan
Fox and we really really liked it yeah
and so we're big fans of Ninja Turtles
to begin with so I had really like
strong expectations of what this movie
needs to be where someone who maybe
doesn't like the Ninja Turtles will have
a completely different opinion Zac what
kind of ninja turtle fan are you like
what did you grow up
growing up Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
by far my favorite show the Kahala
rangers number two so you like the
cartoon okay cool yeah I will say the
most influential thing growing up in my
life yeah for me I loved the Jim Henson
puppeteered movies I did not care for
the third one where they time-travel I
hated that one but I also liked the 1997
TV show called Ninja Turtles the next
mutation which you can now watch on
Netflix which not many people know about
but that's the show that I liked the
most so this movie has a lot of sort of
things that are changed with things that
are kept the same and also cool
references to the older movies for
instance Will Arnett does say like their
heroes in a half-shell and it said kind
of like he's like the joke about Will
Arnett's characters he's sort of the old
guy who doesn't seem to understand
things but there's a lot of great
references to the old shows to the old
cartoon stuff like that I think I think
it's perfect for old fans and made me
bringing in some new fans because it
does have that Michael Bay action film
like modernization yes sir
for instance the shredder in this movie
was such a badass like he is so
intimidating I got chills every time he
came on he reminded me almost look like
the Winter Soldier we're like just this
like total badass samurai who like is
gonna just destroy everyone in his path
and I like how they brought in
technology I mean that's the age we're
living in now it's it shredder has these
ridiculous
claws now a claw and it is like the cool
shot I mean it's totally like ripping
off like the Wolverine but it's still
pretty cool every time he just pops out
the claws but what's the
turtles come into the picture it just
the film just jumps in and I didn't look
at my watch once I didn't take my eyes
off the screen once I was totally
engaged with it so the best scene in the
movie is by far the snow fight yeah the
snow chase see where they're going down
the mountain is incredible
like I think it's maybe five minutes of
the movie but it is one of the most well
executed well shot and the sound design
is incredible and I just like I love the
way everything looks during that slow mo
shots oh there's a handful of them
during the movie and they do the kind of
like you could totally tell they they
got they went through the Michael Bay
sound library cuz it's kind of like that
warp whatever they do this in the
slow-mo it's like a Jew okay so in this
movie there's a lot of changes I think
to the origin story that maybe could
upset some fans but I was fine with it
as far as the the turtles are raised in
a lab with splinter and April O'Neill's
father is the one who sort of is in
charge of project Renaissance which i
think is a cool um now the story of
Hamato Yoshi and the whole revenge thing
with the foot and Oroku sakis isn't
really in this movie like in the
original 1990 version which is something
that I liked and some people don't know
this but it the Ninja Turtles are
actually inspired by daredevil there's a
lot of similarities as far as the Foot
Clan and the hand clan and a lot of
stuff like that
now splinter certainly looks a little
odd he looks kind of more like a donkey
than a rat really that's kind of my only
criticism yeah yeah I didn't love his
look too much I mean I guess the the the
old look of Splinter is so embedded in
our brains were just used to I kind of
missed the furry cute splinter but this
splinter is like a total like he has a
obviously a whip tail that he uses to
fight and like that's totally new and
totally cool yeah so let's talk about
the references a little bit because the
jokes are really funny yeah he's really
really funny there's a lot of great
pop-culture references and also the
jokes are great Michelangelo is
definitely like the funniest person in
the movie are the funniest turtle mutant
I guess and then there's like there's
hollaback girl references there's the
direct references there's lost
references it's great so there's a
really emotional seed
yes agonized almost right
the N like part of it is if you love
those Ninja Turtles you know they're
brothers and I don't want to spoil too
much about what happens but there's a
very emotional sort of speech at the end
of the movie where we actually like
teared up a bit so if you like if you
like ninja turtles I really think you're
gonna like it as much as we did so if
you want to buy tickets click here to
buy your tickets Zac your big Ninja
Turtles fan and you love being a ninja
turtles man yeah and I liked it I think
if you're someone who knows nothing
about Ninja Turtles you still could
enjoy this movie a lot I don't know I
think you would still totally understand
everything that's going on I think that
I think the franchise is gonna get a lot
of new fins yeah and then we read it a
lot on blogs that the the sequel should
have bebop and Rocksteady so I'm really
exposed on that so be sure to subscribe
and comment below tell us who your
favorite Ninja Turtle is what do you
think of the movie you know do you
prefer the old movies the old cartoons
we'd love to know more what you guys
think until next time I'm David and I'm
Zack thanks for watching